microsoft azure is one of the fastest
growing cloud service providers around
with 95 of fortune 500 companies
trusting the platform with their
business
that's why companies across industries
are looking to hire developers with
azure expertise as azure related job
growth
is projected to hit almost 40 percent
over the next decade
with udacity's cloud devops using
microsoft azure nanodegree program
you too can learn the skills you need to
be in demand
in this program you'll develop the
comprehensive knowledge and professional
level skills
you need to streamline the deployment of
cloud-based applications on azure
you will then demonstrate your practical
mastery of these skills in a series of
three projects
where you'll use azure tools to create a
reusable template for deploying custom
web applications
build a continuous delivery pipeline
that deploys a flask machine learning
application
and create disposable test environments
to monitor application performance on
the cloud
experience matters our udacity
instructors cumulatively have more than
10 years of real-world experience
facilitating the deployment of
applications on azure
upon completion of the cloud devops
using microsoft azure nanodegree program
you will be well prepared to take the
microsoft az-400 certification exam
proving your proficiency at designing
and implementing microsoft devops
solutions
fast track your career with the power of
microsoft azure
become an azure cloud devops engineer
today